how the gummy whoa dude
die that's right
see that's shit's leji I got it let us
stick what my welcome back condom and I
don't come on man don't play tricks on
me
come on aren't you freaked her you
[ __ ] touch my peanut or you go down
that's what you get [ __ ] molesting me
piece of [ __ ] I'm still screwed it's
gonna come two of them now why did I
drop sledge eh
all right bring it bring it
that's right pick at you power to your
friend I'm gonna catch you I'm gonna cut
what I [ __ ] that because your power
[ __ ] denied it oh stop it hey I let
spit it hey prepare your back god damn I
missed you man I'm sorry I was hanging
out with some other me but why did this
oh [ __ ] I get it be back I get it don't
way don't [ __ ] with me I'm climbing a
bookshelf I don't even [ __ ] know how
hey yeah yeah climbing bookshelf like
I'm right don't come here because I
don't have a lot of house and I don't
want to die what Rose are you [ __ ]
how convenient alright okay jump down
and see if you can find your way back to
the stairs I'll go back this way
it's not that far though I could
probably help you but whatever Rosa
there's no way past this thing climb
down to the next floor and I'll meet up
with you down there
did I hear those little [ __ ] okay Rosa
Pikachu power wha-hey and stop with it
with the Burke's man getting old man
night prepares piss too you know let's
[ __ ] did he go hate this [ __ ]
bring it
what well I don't give me a [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] or something
come on I can't fight with this not bad
I need a hell thank everything is burnt
and they [ __ ] sneak up on you oh I
see you
what I saw him I was even like come on
bring it you know so our you know books
right we shot a little hell of it Lee's
what the hell man I have to pass one of
those books plain all right ah miss me
[ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ]
teleporting [ __ ] damn I hate them
what are you doing here man rah rah rah
wake up whoa holy [ __ ] bro you left me a
present
I need that [ __ ] awesome
all right come on man
whoa that's right get your power well I
just want a tango I love it it's my
favorite dance her mony let's dance
come on her mone don't you want to dance
with me why the hell don't trust this I
don't trust any of this it's not a
health pack thank god damn that took a
while all right it's just a pistol come
on man come on bring it
I got a pistol oh you're scared now what
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] sure puck back in back
back back back back I regret everything
I want my shotgun back sorry I left you
shoddy hey how you doing girl
oh sorry bruh alright beep ah come here
we need to fight you're not really a
lion man how you doing Brown that's so
good are you now boot that's right
[ __ ] you man hey with your favorite
Pokemon bigger chair mine till nine ten
man [ __ ] orgy going on it don't sit
on each other when prepay is watching
god damn you I want my pepper stop
scissoring disgusting piece of [ __ ]
alright there's a secret close
bombed you hey Barry hey met the piece
hey today all right I got ya
there's the secrets here fine fine with
me
follow the period they said and that's
what we're doing and trust you come on
man
am I going backwards what Rosa you are
freaky girl I'll tell you that you are
1g shut up shut your mouth let don't
fight girl don't like
[ __ ] break dance party I like how
calm you are about things you leave down
fine
I read prepare we gotta take this lady
with that but she's ugly I know she
looks like a boy
Rosa come on Rosa we ain't got all day
are you serious Rosa what's your problem
move Rosa please come Rosa
I'm not I'm not I'm not in the mood
right now Rosa Rosa you look really
beautiful today Rosa Rosa hey Rosa Rosa
send one there Rosa Rosa Rosa cop die
give up back I give up on that lady I
don't need her holy [ __ ] are you coming
or now she's not coming all right fine I
ain't carrying am i whoa what deflection
that awkward eight years ago would put
the kid and the teacher at the same
school in 1997 uh-huh so what do they do
together
oh my god he's on to us but he changed
suit
then he if you remember Anderson Carl a
lot of Carl Anderson's but I bet this is
our guy he was enrolled or sentenced to
an educational rehabilitation center for
the severely troubled I think a row
things secondary on North East 52nd and
Fremont it's been closed for five years
that's one of the worst parts of town
Christ
the cops have just been letting it go to
hell for years and so your face lists
occupations just list some names I'll
take it back to the lab and see what I
can find
good do it I knew it
Rose so you're here too what the hell
Rosa Rosa Rosa
you can't just that's right how'd you
get when you hit me over there
it's Tommy so let's stay down
holy [ __ ] I'm talking to Simon Says hey
Sammy I can see you it's so [ __ ]
obvious okay try a hard time I'm getting
sick of [ __ ] dying at this [ __ ] Taiyo
time it's tired time no you can block if
you like it then you should a [ __ ]
block catch if you make it you power
block it Oh your friend stay down that's
right ha nice teamwork oh oh it's on
we're a team for a second
hi I know you're peppered honey alright
I kill everything I kill everyone hey
she can make a run for it I'm sorry but
what the [ __ ] can't you just die or
something seriously I'm sorry what about
our serial killer axe he's gone same
information we do so school perhaps I
can catch two killers with one net I'll
Drive you there then head back to HQ and
work on that faculty list alright naylet
head weapon but why have cars boot is
the best book I will try to make this
episode a little longer because I didn't
require that much amnesia I don't have a
lot of time today some days I'm a busy
man what can I say just a day in my life
I'm up early in the morning it's Malcolm
is the investigation going well that's
pretty good can awkward how you sneak up
on me that's going as well as it can be
wait what are you doing here how did you
know where to find me exactly hasn't
saw you from across the street I don't
trust coincidences says coincidence I
don't know what your game is here Van
Horn but I've got a job to do if you'll
excuse me yeah that's right Van Horn
it's gonna come for me while I am bend
over for sure Van Horn if that's a real
name Van Horn such a lame name rat [ __ ]
a butcher grab desktop are you kidding
me where I didn't say that
grab bastard holy [ __ ] it's the best
weapon ever no we face a bit
what are you what
yep we're not going there desktop
come on all right let's find sledge it's
better than booth I guess
hi how's it going in here bigoted oh
that's right they could shoo always get
them one way or another they think they
can run but Simon sue would come that
rhymed pretty : it rhymes all right duck
under
come on duck under man there we go
are there sledging and then we unlucky
and then we come back e and then we used
to this legend very conveniently and I
will not stop damn it [ __ ] I got no
timing here today that's all right
hey I hear you man [ __ ] hear you
right
whoa said mom that girl is bad ass
dragon Rose's mom [ __ ] off man
dayum he's got some loving cooking lady
what the hell are you doing sister come
on man I can totally see you [ __ ]
boot you ugly tell stay down man
damn all right what do we got here
showers what the hell come on [ __ ] I
gotta take a piss
I mean a small pipe I love baby I'm in a
very bad shape I know it sucks being a
toilet right what it's coming from is it
trying to don't learn stuff god damn it
stupid masters try to educate loose lips
sink ships
alright I wish I had turned around but
like very enjoys the sky to come
broaching I'll see you next episode of
wherever I may stay awesome breath
[Music]
I'm in the closet
a hater is talking so [ __ ]